on va commencer par se présenter et
après on vous écoutera me présenterai un
peu votre parcours
il y a un nom cyrill décide de changer
de métier il délaisse les cuisines de
grands restaurants pour s'installer
derrière un volant après plusieurs
missions temporaires il aimerait se
stabiliser depuis
et janvier ça va faire un an que charge
de travail et ça c'est assez compliqué d
intérim par ci et par là ne rien de
concret de contact avec les clients
pouvoir l'extérieur du car l'époque
j'étais à l'intérieur surtout à verser
c'est une belle ville donc sa pression
ce jour-là keolis fera passer quatre
entretiens l'opérateur de transport
emploie plus de 280 chauffeur sur son
site versailles et l'entreprise a
accepté de participer aux jo tour depuis
on a des difficultés de à trouver des
candidats
on a une pénurie de candidats sur marché
du travail lié à tout un tas de choses
vous avez eu beaucoup d'extensions
d'offres d'autres d'autres opérateurs de
transport et
et on se retrouve dans une dans une
situation où on doit trouver des
solutions
le job tour a été pensé par le club
d'entreprises face yvelines --l'agence
d'insertion activity ils ont identifié
sélectionnés et accompagner les
candidats donnés aussi l'opportunité à
un maximum de personnes qui sont
éloignés de l'emploi de pouvoir postuler
sur des métiers qu'on considère comme
des métiers qui ont de l'avenir je leur
pose aussi la question comment vous
qu'est ce que vos collègues pour la dire
de vous et puis donc ça ça relève un peu
de la question vos qualités vos axes
d'amélioration et puis ensuite on leur
donne des conseils
neuf entreprises étaient présentes sur
ce premier job tour du service à
domicile aux transports en passant par
la grande distribution
73 candidats ont ainsi pu tenter leur
chance